i want to tell you about a business
principle that has stood the test of
time that is very very important today
and very few people are talking about it
but let me first tell you about the two
mistakes entrepreneurs make one of them
is many times entrepreneurs when they're
winning they think they're going to be
winning forever and then all of a sudden
boom a market crash comes and they lose
everything and sometimes some
entrepreneurs are losing for too long
they think they're going to lose forever
and a massive opportunity comes up and
they miss it look today three trillion
dollars
of retirement wealth was lost in the
first six months of 2022.
one trillion in crypto 80 000 crypto
millionaires wiped out people are
sitting around saying what do we do you
know what that old business principle is
cash is king cash is king today 10 years
ago 50 years ago 100 years ago in 50
years from now by the way i'm not going
to cash like money in your pocket i mean
liquid cash on the bank to be able to
take advantage of opportunities that's
coming up because my prediction is on
the biggest real estate crashes is
around the corner and the key is for you
to be prepared for to persevere so if
you're wondering how i came up with my
conclusion i prepared a one-hour webinar
free webinar that i'm hosting
next tuesday night the 19th at 5 30 p.m
eastern standard time if you haven't yet
registered click on the link above or
below get registered the last webinar we
did a month ago it was fully booked
people complaining about getting on put
it in your calendar once again
next tuesday
at the 19th at 5 30 p.m webinar 5 30 p.m
tuesday the 19th click on the link above
or below get registered and i'll see you
there